seems like nothing will ever satisfy the
Eco nuts he'll bend on destroying
Priceless pieces of art two women
detained in Sweden after smearing paint
on a Monet Greg Gutfeld doesn't even
know what that is and gluing themselves
to the frame how dare you and you know
you're crazy when the view is calling
you out Monette it's so annoying in a
way to use art as a as your cudgel to
not use art we
had leave job your job is to go out and
make people understand why we need to be
careful about the Earth
do you have any monets hanging in your
estate it's Monette sorry yes send your
letters are you asking me that question
you know why the view is mad is because
it makes their cause look bad that's all
it is they don't care about the art
they're on The View
you're saying they don't have refined
taste and art no you do I do you don't
that's the view is performance art oh
they're pretending to care yes no
they're just mad because it makes it
look bad it makes their side look bad
that's all they're policing their own
do we ever do that
[Laughter]
I do think that the there is no one ever
has been persuaded to join the climate
change Movement by watching ridiculous
young people that should be working
instead throw paint on Priceless works
of art literally no one no one is
persuaded at all so to your point I
think that's what you mean like they're
mad because this isn't persuading
anybody and I think that the climate
movement It's So based on fear and not
reality is that we all want a clean
Earth we all also could have logic to
realize that Renewables aren't going to
cut it just yet we need advances in
technology we are working on them but
give people a slow ramp to it rather
than trying to do it all at once all
right Jessica t
so absurd every time I see it I think
it's fake
that it can't actually be that there are
people
destroying these works of art or even
attempting to mess with them
um completely right and everyone Tunes
out like the lions at people's offices
are obviously better than destroying a
Monet or they did a van Gogh a few
months ago
um what's with Priceless pieces of art
someone will pay yeah that's true
true but that's what's wrong with the
billionaire class that's why we want we
need to tax them more
oh right okay
look here's the biggest problem I I have
with that is the security guards
standing by and watching it happen while
those waste of Flesh film it everyone
there there's a clear solution to this
they need to tackle them they need to
prosecute them they need to be punished
civically criminally and by their
parents they need to be on the hook for
whatever that Priceless amount is and
they need to have reparations publicly
they need to be shamed in some type of
way that makes it so that they don't
think this is okay when you look at
these protesters putting Black Ink into
the Rome Fountain and doing this they
have a blase Cavalier quality to them
they think it's okay that's the whole
point if they were disciplined they
wouldn't think it's okay if those videos
were taken off of social media it
wouldn't happen it's it's a sort of a
like an infection you wanted to see
Swedish police brutality in that case
the that's your extrapolation of what I
just said a good tackle the think about
it do I see the PGA golfer that got
tackled for trying to congratulate his
teammate that was an amazing layout can
we get even a fifth of that for these
guys destroying Priceless I mean it is
Sweden you notice they don't do a Kia
but it's like the Lululemon employees
they got they got fired for trying to
stop shoplifting might be the same for
these security guards all right to fund
the Swedish police the only answer hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now